redundancies are at a record level
as the coronavirus pandemic takes a
further toll
uh let's try and bring you some of the
details and all of this the unemployment
rate for the three months to september
uh up 4.8 and that's an increase
of 0.7 from the previous quarter up 0.3
uh from the rate in august there were a
record number of redundancies between
july and september
314 000 of them now that's
up by a record 181 000
on the previous quarter uh let's bring
in our business correspondent paul kelso
who can provide some context to all of
this i mean at first glance
at paul these numbers look pretty grim
they do neil and it's uh that increase
in the headline unemployment rate which
stands at 4.8 percent the highest since
2006 that increase
of 0.3 month on month that's the second
month in a row that unemployment has
increased by a third
of a percent and it's driven by that
rising tide of redundancies the figure
you went through there 314 000
redundancies in the quarter
to september up 181
000. all of this the context of this and
the context outlets that would have been
watched very closely in the treasury was
these figures are for june
uh july through to september this is the
period when companies making these
decisions
about who to keep and who to let go were
facing the end of the furlough scheme
very clearly signal
it will be ending at the end of october
throughout this period that was the
assumption we had some detail at the end
of september
they would have had on the job support
scheme replacing it but many of these
decisions will have been made
with that furlough guillotine moment in
mind of course
belatedly after these figures the
chancellor made the decision to extend
furlough by
a month and then last week rather
hurriedly
right the way through until march and we
get a good sense of why because
if you look at the the rising tide of
unemployment it was rising
very very simply of course now companies
it may be too late for some
but they do have the safety net of
furlough running through to the spring
and of course the subject you've been
discussing all morning the vaccine on
the horizon
which may give companies a little more
confidence about the future and that may
be good news
maybe good news for employees